when you lead with gratitude and
everything that you do is such an
incredible motivator Val Chmerkovskiy is
all about giving back I got a ball with
pencils of promise I believe five years
ago I was able to raise money to build
two schools in Ghana out of all the
accomplishments in my entire life and I
don't have children yet so I'm sure
that'll top everything being a part of
this organization having that pride even
from my mom to see her son making a
difference in this world beyond the
vanity of Hollywood that's one of the
most incredible sources of my prize ET
spoke with val at the pencils of promise
10th anniversary celebration he and
fiancee Jenna Johnson don't have
children yet but when they do Val knows
the kind of values he'll instill in this
the one thing I would love to teach my
kids when I have them and hopefully I
will soon is yes to appreciate the world
around you and to make sure that you
give just as much as you take for now
Val and Jenna are happily engaged in
slowly planning their wedding there's a
lot of things up in the air in our life
which is awesome it's exciting but at
the same time it's really hard to plan
anything in our life so we're looking at
sometime next year what I envision is a
mutual life of eternity together not
necessarily one day that you know will
be the most incredible day yeah it'll be
an incredible day but I'm looking
forward to every day after that and the
pair is busy loving on their sweet new
puppy
it's incredible to be responsible for
someone else another life and then
really is something incredible for me
[Music]